[Musique]
avoir des enfants bonsoir ouf il est
temps qu'on arrive ma neige commence à
fondre et bien des sandwichs étaient
deux petits amis vont être surpris il ne
m'attendent pas mon échelle et hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
ou est-ce que je range les cuillères sur
la table nicolas et pimprenelle là où
tu nous a fait peur
c'est une surprise
et dans cette boîte je vous apporte
quelque chose de la part de pepita et de
cornichons
de la neige de la belle neige blanche de
l'eau montagne
regardez
[Musique]
belle neige blanche elle a fondu en
rouge au que ce togolais
et d'histoire à la
moitié étaient si contents de vous
apporter de la neige
[Musique]
l'autre soit patrice on t'aime bien
quand même
nicolas nous allons consoler ce gros
nounours oui bah brunel consolons
console eu
[Musique]
monsieur non non tu es bien bon à vous
tous les petits garçons
avec les petites il y aussi nous nous tu
es gentil
qui est notre hôte chéri
au bout me fait au groupe les ir
alors je vais vous dire
oh voilà c'est simple tout bonnement
j'adorerais en font
ils mentent dont à lui
nuit dis moi nous nous irons tu reviens
bientôt j'espère bien
ah oui nous nous serions
bon je viendrai trop haut
[Musique]
alors tu ne peux tu restes non damien
bonne nuit les petits la jette un liner
fait pour
agm annonce ennuie pas prenait lé gars
bien du frère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en patron quelle déception ma belle
neige était fou dit mais nicolas et
pimprenelle mon consoler le cher petit
ils sont très gentils allons en route
demain je le referai une autre surprise
la nuit les enfants embrasser bien fort
vos parents faites votre toilette elle
avait voulu dans l'oublié pas aller
sagement vous coucher comme nicolas et
pimprenelle et faute de pauvres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
on